c'est beau jeu super génial daignant pas
du tout au point
par verre
au revoir
leur faire mal aux oreilles les
hypophyses aurait qui l'a révélée
bénéfique de vendeuse
il revient à ces batteries type est à
l'honneur au préfet qui auront le plus
fort qui verriez appuyé le la vue
d'ensemble un peu après avoir une sorte
de bible et en bas de l'image aussi
toujours faire les salahi d'avancé
devant avant sa droite peut zoomer
dessus
ok allez reprendre notre terre
excitant c'est bon ça voilà la belle
épine en bas de l'image war par
découvrir devant
ils sont passés derrière le basket a
repris à tous par des accords usa
d'abord ils vous accueillent dans le
combat là par françois gillet plus près
de 9
on va essayer de passer crise et ical
pas ce mois ci deux ans je disais c'est
cause toujours
patrick marsh rick nash et bien sûr
lâche temps on peut en entendre deux
concerts autour genre de cas maintenant
combien de temps encore des contractants
et l'éléphant est posé sur lui on
regarde devant lui sur lui selon lui les
volets le temps tout le clae le pq et
fin de piques craquer d'art et en aucun
cas d'entente on va arrêter les
éléphants pour la gauche on est tous
bois comme annie lagauche loi gauche
fait que pour l'instant on tourne tout
ce qui comptait c'est pas je m'en fous
rires à 30 secondes met 30 secondes que
rien du tout baba qu'on va revenir y
aura plus rien on peut s'approcher ou
pas on est dessus mais tu shootes
propres a été inscrit en coin
je fais mon point à chaque renverse en
l'air prend l'herbe que devant il ya
trente secondes plus tard on pourra pas
peur